あの題名の通りなんですけど
ああああああああ
それじゃあぐーんあーんって言ったんですよファービーを
[音楽]
今流行ってたんですけどうわなんだこれやばいキモイと思って
ん
で名見てみたなぁ完全に女の女なんですよ
4位
なんかやっぱ育て方でファービってすごい変わるらしくて
なんか何を俺がかっこいいからかな
やっぱ4男らしいかつ飼い主だったらきっと
ファミマ惚れて女の子になるんですよなんでも
すっかり乙女のサービになっちゃいましたバイバイ
どう思いますねこの顔
まずまつげが糞長いんですよねねあー
くださっハハッハってれんだよ
おい
判明ウチはウチだけをしてるあ
ぜひうううううっ
ai love you
はあああいいいい
はいうんもう目ハートになりますもんで i love you って言ったら
うーん今までのファービーより全然可愛いんですよねこうめが違うだけで全然関わり
ますね
表現力が作っ
なんだなんだなんだ
[音楽]
動作動作
動作
[音楽]
これも普通にあかーんと言いますお前通すタイプか
スマホのアプリでさあ微熱があるんですよ
[音楽]
なんか召し上げよ
を負った
ん
んう
ろんぞと
葵
とっ
乗り合わせて帰ってくるんですよ
translator よこれで何言ってるかわかるんですよ
変なも使えばならないか
パジェロわー
まあなんか中にいくという
あーもっと話してください初期ん
大前が来校前ゴス何って名前
意外と今回のサーベイはなめちゃいけません
た小皿でも全然楽しめると思うんで
ぜひ
腰寂しくなくなるんで買ってみてください
なあ
起きろ
もちろ
おい
起きてくれ
勝ち年
おやすみ